It's garlic, a good substitute for a blood thinner.
Well, legally, I can't say that you should change anything from a medical blood thinner if that's what you would prescribe.
But from a nutritional perspective, garlic is probably the strongest blood thinner that exists from a nutritional dietary perspective.
I would caution somebody who's on a blood thinner to not be taking too much garlic.
You could have too much blood thinning and some capillary fragility and easy bruising and things that's what you should be looking for.
Garlic is not only a natural blood thinner, but it is a really good thing to kill infections in the blood.
People that have issues with bowel, heart valve issues, which is not uncommon, especially with people with cardio-legally, in large carts, taking garlic can be beneficial.
You have to be careful with this. Garlic is a TH1 stimulator. That means it's an immune stimulator.
So if you do have an autoimmune disease, you can't take garlic on a regular basis anyhow.
So it will be helping your body kill. That would have antibodies against, which is your own tissue.
So you could use it for a short period of time.
Like any immune stimulator, if you have an autoimmune disease, it doesn't mean you can never take immune stimulators,
if you have a doubt that the cold or something, but you would take a long turn.